EPEL one here the first thing that I
would do is I would do that power
property by bringing that coefficient up
as a power okay so I'm going to take
these coefficients bring them up as
powers okay like so okay so if we
simplify that a little bit further you
can see this is going to be log base 3
of X to the negative 1/2 plus log base 3
of Y cubed squared because I brought
that 2 up and then over here we have
minus log base 3 of 2 to the 1/3 power
okay now just to simplify a little bit
more when you have a negative exponent
that tells you to take the reciprocal
and remember the 1/2 power is actually
the square root so this is actually
going to be log base 3 of 1 over the
square root of x okay this one over here
log base 3 of Y to the 6th power because
remember power to power you multiply and
then over here we have log base 3 and
then the 1/3 power is actually the cube
root of 2 so remember the denominator is
the root and the numerator is the power
okay with these rational exponents and
then the next step what we're going to
do is when you add you multiply the
arguments but when you subtract you
divide so what we're gonna do is we're
gonna condense this all into one log now
so we've got log base 3 of 1 over the
square root of x okay multiply by Y to
the 6 so I'm gonna write y to the sixth
in the numerator and then here we're
subtracting so that's like dividing so
I'm gonna put that in the denominator
the cube root of 2 and then that's
basically it you can leave it like that
or if you wanted to take it a step
further you could rationalize the
denominator to get rid of these radicals
in the denominator but for right now I'm
gonna leave it just like that
okay so for example number two same idea
we want to try to condense it down into
one log so the first thing I'm going to
do here is I'm going to bring these
coefficients up as powers so I'm gonna
take the 3 bring that up as a power and
so on so that's going to give us a log
base two of X to the one-fifth power
plus log base two of Y okay and all
that's being multiplied by one half and
then over here our minus log base 2 of
Z cubed because we brought that three up
okay now let's work with the inside the
parentheses here when we add as long as
you have the same base which we have
base two we can multiply those arguments
together so we can write this as log
base two of X to the one-fifth Y okay
and then you can see that one half in
front now remember when you have that
coefficient you can bring this up as a
power so I'm just going to show that
right there and then over here we have
minus log base 2 of Z cube okay now when
you have a power to a power you multiply
right so we don't see it but there's
actually a one there but what I'm going
to do is I'm going to distribute that
one half to both of those exponents so
we have log base two of X to the one
tenth power now Y to the one half power
okay and remember when we subtract what
do we do we divide right so this
whatever you're subtracting that part is
going to go in the denominator so this
is over Z cubed and we can leave it like
that but I'm going to simplify it a
little bit more I'm going to say this is
a log base two X to the one tenth power
is really like the tenth root of X Y to
the one half power is like the square
root of Y and that's all over Z cubed
and I'm just going to put a bracket
around all of that so what we did is we
condense this all into one logarithm so
I hope that helps you to understand how
to work with condensing logs a little
bit better I'll put a link to another
video that I did talk about talking
about condensing logs so if you want
some more practice and then lastly you
know if you're preparing for the AC T or
the SAT check out my two courses my huge
AC t-- math review video course and my
huge SAT math review video course and
I'll have links for those in the
description so I'll talk to you in the
next video and now we'll do some more
math then